not getting much coverage I should look
for more towers to activate
hello happy Thursday
happy Thursday welcome I wish we were
playing doom cuz I'd be like welcome to
hell but it's not we're not playing -
spider-man is actually out and what and
about you can I guess you can play it
now yeah I think digital readers are
there unlocked retail they might come
here tomorrow they might arrive tomorrow
so if you did so it was like a worldwide
release with Australia yeah okay awesome
leading the way cool let's just get into
it
cuz I know you've been having a lot of
fun with it we gave the game a 9
yes and yeah we're gonna we're gonna try
not to do too many story beat spoilers
right we're gonna meet you I think like
if I hit a couple yeah it's kind of
impossible to do absolutely no spoilers
unless you got like I don't know just
ignore like all the story missions all
the but even still you're gonna get a
little like a couple of pop ups here and
there from like a radio source or
whatever so this is super fair warning
right now even though there's slight
delay that there might and there will
probably be some spoilers but we're
gonna try our best not to do they'll be
very minor but even still like I know
that a lot of people just want to go
into the game completely fresh in which
case you probably should be watching
livestream all right here we go
based Karp 20 says for me digital comes
out in five hours okay
Sanji says 19 hours left for me in the
u.s. houses please find Marvel landmarks
aside work man will do that yeah maybe a
few first things first let's let's do
this tower okay because that's what
Spiderman always is known for are these
kind of like towers in a sense like like
breath of the wild tower yeah basically
they like uncover your map but they're
there since you are Spider Man there's a
lot less to worry about and getting to
them you can just run up outside the
wall and that's got to be like one of
the more gratifying things to do in this
game is just like traversal yeah
movement mechanics hip swing if you
followed anything about this game in the
last couple years you know that
like it's all about the traversal and
okay got points for freefall like you
look at you just and how you just wow
City no pain
nope I would have been like my back okay
so first things first we're gonna solve
this crime here alright um so those
crimes like throughout the city and in
each one of them you'll have to like
save them from cars you have to beat up
some criminals robbing a bank or
something like that
okay we can scan the environment what
would you call that because you know
Batman had his his kind of pulse yeah
it's a spicy sense Spidey said man you
didn't have the little a little like
comic book place you know if I could put
like a like a little thing behind your
head wear it because I've seen it in the
game for sure it'll trigger
okay so guy hit and run how could he
possibly be like totally okay and
standing after that well he wasn't he
wasn't crushed she was just pinned I
think that's the right word all right so
one of my favorite things about the game
so far is that I was a kidnapping but if
you see in the in the mini-map there's a
little backpack icon and each one of
those they're scattered throughout the
city each one of them will have like a
little Easter Egg for spider-man's you
know past life because this is somebody
was at several years after he's already
become spider-man so he's like fought a
whole bunch of criminals follow whole
bunch of bad guys that we all know
already so he has a history and they're
all stored in these little backpacks
here so this is like when he was
delivering pizzas doing as a teenager or
in college a little Easter Egg right
there and there's 55 all throughout the
city fun times how's the FPS as Ethan
Hodgins I think it's good like there I
think it from what I remember reading it
runs a lock 30 okay um but like with the
motion blur it looks really smooth
regardless like there aren't any hitches
at all
and we are playing on approach for those
that may or may not ask but get that out
there
James Gleason wants to know is this like
the Batman games I would say no like the
the whoops if the closest comparison to
the Batman games is obviously going to
be the combat but even still it's very
very different Thanks what's up slappy
noodle aka rob son
how're you guys doing a CTL euro college
we're good we're doing well I'm doing
well at least it's a Thursday
I've lost the the week's been weird
because we have Monday off yeah like it
keeps throwing me off like it's
obviously a good thing one to have
Monday as a holiday and two because it
shortens the workweek but it's kind of
throwing me for a little bit of I
thought yesterday was Thursday so I got
another backpack you know the backpack
right here little Oscorp I interviewed
there what dr. Octavius offered the
chance to really make a difference such
a philanthropist that Peter yeah well I
mean that's his life now he goes from
reporter photographer at Daily Bugle to
big-time scientist alright let's do one
of these so thanks guy gamer says you
boys are handsome oh thank you I just
got a text from Doc just an idea Fred
spidey gadget man does he ever stop
inventing so we got a lot of gadgets
here too which is always nice and yeah
like skilltree to write our collectibles
easy ass crime collectibles easy I would
say yes um in that you don't really need
to do a whole lot there are some that
you need to like you know chase stuff
around a little bit but as far as
finding they're not too bad thanks
technically it's out in Australia like
we have a early code which obviously
like this place some people will say in
a couple hours it can play others saying
like longer it officially releases
tomorrow I would I would guess like what
9 p.m. tonight not if it hasn't already
unlocked in some cases some people were
saying in four to five hours alright so
these are the hideouts basically like
huge arenas with bunch of bad guys in a
so we can we can approach them
stealthily if we wanted to I'll leave
that up to you soon
like how don't they see you man that
you're wearing red and we always see me
naptime nobody heard that either a lot
of web to use for one guy like how do
they not see him it's like dangling on I
think eventually they'll they'll spot
them and be like hey this guy's all
webbed up must be some kind of spider
around here that's the the web shot
sounds okay yeah that guy saw me shorter
you can is this Marvel wins Marvel oh
forgot to get my once kill okay so you
have three like trees you can go through
yeah so well yeah let's take a look at
this real quick so the three trees are
innovator defender and web slinger so
innovator is more it's more about
interacting with the enemies in their
weapons so like one one tree you can go
down or one branch you can go down this
is like yanking enemies weapons away and
throwing the back of them or like
swinging them around and then defender
is more like defensive abilities you
know you can get a unlock a perfect
dodge and see what's a good one here
you can like instantly take down people
from far away if you dodge right and
then webslinger is the one that I think
it's the best okay or you're saying
you're saying like if you were to start
cuz like obviously you're gonna have to
make decisions right yeah and it's not
that you won't unlock everything because
I'm sure as you get through the whole
game you'll get everything but yeah your
your preference would be to start going
down webslinger heavily yeah I would say
so just because like you're gonna spend
so much your time early on like going
from one place to another and you're not
I know it just it just makes the
beginning hours of the game just more
fun in my opinion okay cool
little pro tip from Joey can you be a
silent neighbor yes you can I mean
technically he could have stealth this
way hope like through the whole hideout
out as soon right yeah right
we got suit powers what a bunch of thugs
with no weapons over here boys and yeah
that's one of his finishers so that's
when you got your focus bar full yeah oh
wow there's a lot of guys now yeah
that'll be about five weeks lying when
you said this was like an arena oh here
have a little bit nada I like how that
didn't hit you at all but got everyone
else well your spider-man oh they got
guns now they got guns so I'm gonna go
ahead and take care of that guy real
quick that guy has a gun too it's gonna
OH
see ya hey spider-man wouldn't do that
they actually do not die oh really so if
they fall off you'll see them get
widowed well that guy's just alright by
the building dude planned you can see
him like where do you win okay maybe he
did die but usually usually they'll get
like Webb to the side of a wall at some
point I see spider-man doesn't kill ya
that's a perfect dodge nice so if you
have to be pretty precise with that or
do you think it's a little generous it's
pretty generous just it's like once the
this the spicy scents turns blue then
you'll have like that window and you can
have there are towns too taking preset
oh Jesus Bertie as I say like do you
feel like it's pretty rewarding to do it
like like would you try to do it like as
frequently as possible
oh yeah definitely especially later on
you can get a suit power that will slow
down time every time you perfect dodge
oh so like which time nice I was gonna
ask if there's like anything like that
or even like what is it in God of War
Nick in the combat so far it's here just
like the kind of stuff you can do and
you don't even have like everything it
get Rick alright forgot to have the
impact web too so in addition to like
the suit powers got the gadgets or food
just like immediately impact on like
against the wall and yeah guessing you
can't spam that too often though no so
you only have a couple of charges for
that one but if you go back to like the
regular one you can you can shoot it off
I reload those cartridges man
you can take them and swing around throw
them off the side of ability if you want
let me do that eventually
oh no the cement mixer yeah
thousand watts amendments and then toss
them how many enemy types is crime um I
think there's about five or six total
like later on the game will you'll come
come across some different ones but for
right now they'll be like actually
there's like the main guys there's guys
with shields is the the long-range ones
with guns and then there's also brutes
which yeah I saw those guys yeah they
can't they can't be like they can't be
zipped to so there's a guy shield well
my favorite things about like these
encounters is that you don't need to
stay on the ground floor you can swing
around the the building if you want and
just like wow that's awesome and just
you can pretty much pick your own
battles here for the gun guy later okay
this is a little trippy I don't know if
I like that which a stun grenade yeah oh
is okay I thought it was because you're
a little help but if that's the stuff
your name that totally makes sense
yeah oh this is getting crazy later Joey
later you are making me so anxious be
responsible at that power don't kill
them we're trying what's up Alex Barros
how you doing what's up - MMH I think
from earlier giving serious thought to
buy a ps4 dress for this yeah I mean
Joey is really enjoying it I was I asked
him briefly like right before oh yeah
Wow
Wow Joey it's okay we're waking up early
yeah it's early oh but back to what I
was saying I was saying that I was
talking to enjoy before him I was like
you know like where do you put this on
your list like so far for 2018 obviously
there's you know a lot a lot of good
stuff that's come out this year and more
stuff even to come and I think you said
like it's like right now for you like
it's this in God of War I have it I
haven't decided completely but it's up
there there's a lot and wave I there we
go so like in this case where there's
like 10 subs right you know whatever you
want to call them right what's your best
like area-of-effect
type or is there no kind of like you
won't have one right now I've got it oh
that was nice
that's saying I can say just knock
everyone off a building so you don't
need to fight them
give me some Marvel 3 here yeah whip
sling
no that's weird so you can finish the
wit oh you're on the final way yeah okay
guys I was like extremes let's have
bought a ps4 just for this thanks
is there difficulty settings as Moe
Malik or is it fixed like Dark Souls
kind of there are three difficulty
settings at the moment so there I think
it's friendly which is like all else a
rocket friendly there's amazing and then
spectacular which spectacular is like I
haven't I haven't tried it yet but I
know it's pretty well a little slide
between his legs yeah so the shoe guys
you have to like get rid of this bazooka
man aerial combat school says cover a -
I love spider-man I wanna play now but
it's only on ps4 sorry X brain
jubilation says there's five
difficulties five and maybe with the
patch because he said oh yeah yeah the
culture will be old - yeah yeah there's
three difficult settings plus new game
plus at launch there's new one we don't
have new game+ yet yeah right because I
was hoping mentioned yeah I was hoping
it would uh be released before the
stream because I have another save which
I've under presented yeah so that would
be cool let's have Bob Jones to the
person asking can you change seats you
can there are a bunch in this game of
which you know are not gonna show too
many today but we're eventually going to
do a video with the bunch of suits those
suits as you can see with this suit they
have powers which is cool because that
at least that gives you like it'll
change your game style like he said like
what there's one where it kind of gives
you that slow down time which is cool
you're styling on them I just finished
it with the impact would very
anticlimactic places lockdown captain
actually web down
Fisk has more construction sites
throughout the city betting their fronts
to keep an eye out and report in if you
see anything suspicious
jubilation she is saying because like
when we're knocking them off its kind of
saying what you said is oh yeah it gets
stuck to a wall they never die which is
pretty plain so like you'll just see the
building and I know just the one to
start with okay I think we unlock the
landmarks Thanks
so I think is this first one yeah
all right go there first sweet and you
had some skill points don't forget about
those are you doing Severus winging
around we'll do some a little bit of
story but not too much probably and then
we'll also do like you know he did a
hideout type thing there you know look
for like some collectibles here and
there we're gonna try not to spoil too
much but you know obviously as I
mentioned earlier it's hard to you know
play the game and not spoil some stuff
we're just gonna try to avoid like big
ones right yeah gamespot what are these
tokens about the tokens Oh
so when I completed that hideout I got
two base tokens and so each and so each
each time you complete a hideout or you
do a crime of any type you'll get
basically a currency and you be able to
use those to buy new skills new gadgets
new suit mods and suits themselves okay
cool so it feeds into it yeah how about
let's put one on all right
let's see what we have Masek the classic
Oh so these I think these five will be
open like right away okay for you to buy
like that Wow look at that gasps one's
kind of weird sound of silence and so
each one also hat will unlock a power
that you can use with any suit like you
don't need to oh really
so like yes spidery unlocks a decoy but
you don't need to be wearing that suit
that's usual actually I like that a lot
because sometimes you want to have the
fashion but have the ability from
something else
so only have that one so let me do this
one the repaired suit so that unlocks
the web process yeah I hope you guys can
play soon a lot of people just excited
and wanting to play yeah I'm glad you
guys are tuning in obviously appreciate
you guys hanging out with me and Joey if
you didn't know games about live goes
live every day Monday to Friday sorry on
a week on a weekly basis there at 11:00
a.m. Pacific Standard Time
so come hang out we'll play games you
know early if we get to you know in this
case we're kind of early but based off
the Australia release and then you know
try out previews betas alphas all that
stuff next week we're gonna do some call
duty blackout yeah that one's gonna be
interesting I'm really curious like I'm
actually legit curious like what their
spin on battle royale will be if it'll
feel good yeah because I feel like a lot
of that games blackout you know there's
some stuff riding online here because
you know essentially if you think about
it they don't have a campaign anymore
which to me that means that pretty much
favored you know the battle royale mode
for that even though that they won't say
that from yeah right because they still
have zombies they have like I think like
three different like naps or stories but
there's I thought there was no story
mode or there's no like campaign yeah
there is cause a blackout I don't know
if they specifically said like oh we
ditched campaign for blackout like
they'll never I don't
they'll ever say something like that or
if they has it maybe I just didn't hear
them say that but you know like in my
mind it's like they made a trade yeah
but but to me it's like what is out of
the hundred percent of people that play
call of duty right like how many people
actually go through campaign you know I
figure you like a good amount I bet you
that number is not as high as you think
and most people five play ball like that
viewing a pretty tough decision to make
if you think that the majority of your
players are actually doing that but yeah
all right so we unlocked landmarks so
this is actually one of my favorite
collectibles aside from the backpacks
and so what you'll be able to do is like
visit can I hang up I think I did that
once to end me and then he he called her
back and he was like sorry sorry I hung
up on you or something like that
and she continued the conversation which
I thought was pretty cool so you can't
hang up on some people but it's like if
you if you are talking someone and then
you do you interact with something yeah
so here's another landmark mohit asks is
the game worthwhile I think that's kind
of up to you our review is up again we
gave it a 9 out of 10 you know which is
obviously a pretty good score maybe
better than pretty good obviously but um
you know I think if you like spider-man
you know I think it's it's definitely a
game you want to check out link but oh
the guy here
random dog on the street yeah I would
think like you know wouldn't it be
awkward to see spider-man beat someone
up I would think that more than what
have their cell phones out to be like oh
you know they do they like they pull out
their cameras and like try to take
selfies with you bill goon
nyam says I think it looks bland well I
mean we're still pretty early in the
game and I'm also just walking on the
street this is show like street-level
stuff isn't yeah classic New York New
York city traffic ring d-link one zero
one three says is there a resolution
mode and performance mode yeah so there
is a performance mode because it's
locked at 30 but there is like a super
sampling option
what's up Diego are you
yeah daph Demi Moore says pift it's
definitely not bland watch when he gets
into combat yeah and like you said like
we're still missing like a lot of
abilities and all that stuff I think I
think it looks fun I mean just like
watching you run around and like web
sling just looks like fun
you know yeah like you'll get so many
more abilities that will make it like a
lot more satisfying are there I would
assume there's probably something like
this already but there's probably like
are there like Time Trial stuff where
you're like slips oh yeah what's up
gamer yeah I'm just gonna say the rest
of that part your name yeah how does
this stick to the wall work is that a
circle thing or is it automatic
oh I mean like when he's running out the
walls I'm guessing maybe or maybe like
when you jump onto a wall can you like
stay on the wall is it something you do
manually or is it automatic yeah so when
you when you jump against the wall
you'll if you just don't hold anything
you'll just you know crawl on it yeah if
you hold hard drop you hold R - you'll
start running you'll go like that and
you can run sideways which other I like
in the city looks great
and so III have to like talk about it
rose a little bit because like okay so
in order to swing you just hold r2 then
you let go and you can swing but like
you can hello is there how do I describe
this I can't get into your mind so I
can't help you okay so I'll start with
this like if you do l2 and r2 right
you'll do that point launch which is
like that and then you can jump off of
like any point because we're saying you
can get some next-level movement yeah so
you can quickly zip to like anywhere
that has a reticle like this and then
jump at the right time and you'll launch
off of it but things like that's it's so
well incorporated with your regular
swing because all you need to do is hit
l2 because you're holding r2 already
while you're swinging it's not like you
need to release it and then hit both of
them at the same time you just go like
that then you're just launching
everywhere
what's that Doctor Strange is based you
just passed the doctor changes place Oh
what where someone said yeah that was
sanctum cinq-cinq
oh yeah so yeah there are little low
Easter eggs for like other Marvel
properties I think they're landmarks on
here let me check real quick
yes you uh-huh frame rate should be fine
Geralt of Rivia um I haven't seen any
frame drops in terms of my streaming
platform but if you're having
difficulties apologize I guess but I
don't think anyone else in chat is
having problems but this game is 30fps
with motion blur though yes that is
correct so if you're talking about that
then your landlord Peter he's talking
about this one right here yeah this
one's synced I'm saying whoa sorry like
how you can't you can't hurt the people
on here but you can still like Earl and
really close them and what just getting
knocked over the top big there's a map
feels as 8 and it is it's pretty big
like it's obviously it's not gonna be a
one-to-one replica of Manhattan but it's
it's pretty close like there's you have
all the landmarks that you are familiar
with but it's a decent sized map nice
dr. Mueller asking when you push people
off walls do you automatically stick
people to the walls or you can you bring
them back before they fall hmm if you're
like fighting a dude and you like kick
them off yeah I feel like can you pull
them back I don't think you can you can
only like automatically step to the wall
you can only web up people when they're
on the ground and throw them that way
Tom Flags asking what's the variations
in gameplay variations
oh there's quite a bit like you'll spend
longtime web-swing mostly just to like
get around and that's but even that in
and of itself is pretty pretty like
varied like especially like you were
showing like the different like things
you can do and like you said some are
like are you missing some abilities yeah
a good number of a build-up to so we're
early in the game as mentioned earlier
so you know he's not gonna be able to do
everything it would have been nice as
Joey mentioned earlier if we could have
got into New Game+ because he had a
hundred percent original save using
rocks
yeah just like it's really save on Rob's
just because one don't get too involved
into like the story areas so what are we
working on that here's some crimes so as
a kidnapping somewhere this guy in a
trunk
what what I'm surprising time up or
anything oh dear sweet Manasa
can you do photo one yet yes you can
let's go into this fight first and take
a couple photos oh now there's a bunch
of thugs get a photo mode here which it
was just added I think to the game like
yesterday so we can do some pretty cool
stuff with this so let's swing the
camera around
John Luke says the music sounds very Sam
Remy
movies yeah it does let's go
dealing says the string keeps dropping
the stream is so laggy
alright I will try to mix it I will fix
it even though should be fine
let me see it's getting nice blur going
here I mean look too much all things
considered I don't know John Luke is it
lagging for you because I asked because
I'm not dropping frames on my end
so speaking of frames we got some frames
for the photo here you can do like a
billboard I think the cool one we're
gonna pro guys is the comic book cover
stream is fine for me says John stream
responses the other john marston red
dead no lag for me says being monkey
it's his problem okay I'm just not gonna
touch anything because like I said I I
on my end everything looks good like it
should be fine and so and I'm getting
that back from chat so I'm sorry if you
guys are having those problems what I do
if you're having those frame lags is it
could be bandwidth you know could be
your machine I would drop your
resolution down to like 720p or
something if you're getting lag
appreciate everyone commenting no lag
now most people saying no drops or
anything so we're just gonna oh yeah
sorry I didn't even notice your me doing
this explaining and reading the little
like paper things they're kind of really
like Deadpool and like silly stuff like
that that's pretty cool I don't know if
I would use this as a cover I know Sarah
Lee but it's cool that you can make one
yeah you can do like any time basically
you have yeah I think you are gonna have
a lot of fun with that because if you
seem like a lot of the like the really
good god of war photo photo mode like
entries I think they had a contest for
it like couple weeks ago they're really
good can you save them as themes on the
homepage that pic mode is suite 272 LCD
then right back into swinging
can you beat the game without shooting a
single web no there I mean there are
some like story moments that you need to
shoot it but apart from that I guess you
could it would just be oh very difficult
is it easy to web looking what the
controls does it feel easy or do they is
it messy as Joey said pretty seamless
pretty good yeah we like it really good
very comfortable very like at some point
it just becomes like an extension of you
like you are the Spider Man yeah and
yeah like you said I like that you know
as you gain some of these web slinging
abilities and all that like it does let
you play around with things it's not
just like oh here I'm just gonna web
sling you know I might throw in you know
like a I know you pull yourself and then
jump as you showed earlier or other
other things too yeah run on the walls
and then you know it just becomes like a
huge playground basically alright we're
next
oh man go through this hmm a little
movie moment yo I need this game yeah
you really do of course finally this is
it actually took a while for someone to
say puddles to be honest like real talk
like we lasted a good amount of time
before someone actually brought up
puddles okay here's a question do we
want to do another story mission I think
it's fine I mean we gave okay I'm giving
warning again but we're gonna do a story
mission cuz why not like we're early
right how how long do you think we're
here we are like 7% into the game
alright there you go so there you go
alright guys gonna re upload this later
yeah I mean like the DVR'd version or
the vaad version should go up after but
it's gonna be based off of this so if
you're having issues then you know there
could be problems but we're also on game
SWAT calm you can check it out on the
site watch it'll be a definitely a Avadh
there as well
I'm gonna do some crime first some crime
solving how did he know we were in these
streets
Oh nice Dodge give the wall I mean
that's cool I like that you don't
necessarily have invulnerability I guess
you know so you always have whoops
like in terms of like how much damage
you're actually taking oh that's new
[Music]
thug crimes in Chinatown pretty standard
you know they would be in an alley with
pipes you know if you guys watch any
like good Chinese like old-school
Chinese gangster movie triad movie
they're always just in the street in a
narrow alley with pipes I think I've
been young in the dangerous they had
those like want to say they were using
the you know those bulbs like there's
really long balls oh yeah those for us
and with fluorescent lights so here we
go we got Jay Joe and Jamison oh nice
podcast
[Music]
yeah so he'll pop up at like random
times to talk about usually you know
he's just like berating spider-man a lot
of times but he'll it'll be like
incorporate into the story moments like
if you do something in the game he'll
like talk about that later on I think
it's pretty cool
yeah no problem dealing thanks for
stopping by
can you see in every window uh yeah
actually you can't there's no there
isn't
stuff in everyone to put the fact that
there is like depth to it it's not just
like a flat texture is actually pretty
cool
nice yeah I really like that Dodge it's
just like boom web ball Steven oh so you
do have like an AoE yeah that's the lead
our first one is web powers okay where's
sue powers that's awesome
like I like yeah everyone oh no not you
finish him
spider-man's done some pretty sure
training managers the neck is broken
training I had you Silva super
professional stream I dig it thank you
appreciate it
Dalton Duncan asking about a homecoming
suit first and so is Antonio's oh that
is in the game yes do not have yet but
yeah unfortunately this is ps4 Pro
Yozora curses wait what he's a podcaster
not even a youtuber I guess so
he's like a radio host so what buttons
you use for web something he said it was
l2u right r2 and r3 notes yeah and then
like you know when you get close to top
you can press thanks just long for
confirming that appreciate it like
Brandon he actually just switched to
this suit so you can use it for a little
bit longer like that abilities pretty
cool the web blossom but as you
mentioned you're not tied to actually
using the suit right for the ability
yeah so you can switch it off okay I
switch in a little bit gonna go see some
Aunt May here
alright good ol Aunt May switch out my
spider she is she a fox like in a
homecoming in homecoming
she was quite attractive for an Aunt May
there hey I'm just saying
compared to other armies who are usually
a lot older I think she's on the older
side okay so just just to like purposes
and me works at a homeless shelter okay
okay Aunt May thing to do or just like
food and emergencies like you Sara the
food emergency aid shelter training
feast as mentioned this is story right
you said yeah so we're early on but I'm
gonna throw it out there again if you're
scared if you don't want to see stuff
you can back out you want to turn on
subtitles oh yeah Thank You Kai for that
I always forget cuz like for us like
when we're recording we don't want to
see that the the subtitles like when
we're on stream definitely want to put
the subtitles up so thanks for that one
Ryan it is not on Xbox No it is a
exclusive so who played Aunt May in
homecoming I actually didn't watch
homecoming oh really
yeah I know I keep I keep hearing that I
[Music]
know yet
oh really no I don't want the whole wiki
of yeah the person I like the first link
is why quote hot Aunt May is a problem
yeah see that's what I'm saying I was
like I'm not lying when I said she was a
fox you know it was like this is not the
up May I know this is this is definitely
aunt territory here she's beautiful
so who played her a Marissa timing right
you can tell me so he says yeah we're
gonna say that oh I thought you were
like wasn't that you weren't sure
Marissa Tomei was yes it was very
awkward like this is more of an autumn a
to me yeah you know he's right five
years ago you walked in here and told me
you were inspired by my mission to help
other people keep asking about Stanley
can we help me thank you or is there one
no no there's for many more years of
service Nicholas Meyer use more or less
can attach people the buildings in some
cases if you knock them off they kind of
automatically get attached like that
impact web does the impact web or if
they're all webbed up and you like swing
them around and throw them against the
wall though automatically stick to
anymore for no reason I can't do the
conversion for you but if you're in
Europe you should have the like game
sooner than like someone that's waiting
for Pacific Standard Time because they
did a worldwide release trailer
because that's you know New Zealand
Australia would be the first region to
get it one of me to my can ask you a
question but it's not that important
jubilation says Stanley does have a
cameo so cool
[Music]
plays the animated spider-man for the
cartoons you want to switch seats let me
see what I have because I have the five
base ones yeah and so as you level up
you'll unlock more okay so not just
based on leveling it's not like yeah or
anything a suit looks clean nighttime
whoo I like this - I was gonna ask you
about the day/night cycle yeah so like
it you can't control it directly from
your um but as you go through the story
beats though I change from day to night
the Sun Trent skeleton they don't even
do the t's we're like they gave me like
it's like a slightly go away this one
question mark question mark question
mark alright so what are you gonna
change to here see I can buy all I don't
have enough backpacks so like yeah
that's the thing you need the tokens in
order to buy the suits they're really so
yeah unlock it at a level but then you
need to find stuff to them man yeah so
like this one I have a suit the other
one you're on is that was a more dick
smart man
so let me let's go get some let's go
grab some backpacks and then we'll
unlock oh you're not like lock to story
you can still like no get the backpacks
this might be in between every story
mission you you're free to do whatever
you want cool so let's go
nighttime swinging is actually really
cool like I look like I'm liking the
difference just visually you know cities
big cities always look pretty awesome at
night
what's the last one ask Dalton Duncan I
don't know you want to talk you can I
don't know how big of a spoiler is it
Peter
never know I don't remember that name of
the last one is the Marvel office in the
game there's ask gin time because it's
on 50th and 7th Avenue the Marvel Comics
office oh and we can we can try to find
it here
Jacob asking was your favorite suit in
the game favorite suit there are some
really really weird suits in the game
like I have never seen before I don't
know if I doing ring actually talking
about them there's one where he's just
basically like do I want to say we think
I know no that's up to you I leave that
up to you as for me someone that hasn't
played it later Antonia thanks for
stopping by
Abu if it's lagging for you I'm not sure
what to tell you could be your internet
could be your machine or your you know
possibly your phone or latency because
most people have told me it's fine the
game does run at 30fps though locked
with motion blur so go find your
backpack what's up Adam how you doing
well nailed it stuck the landing slow
roll don't mind me five-o just doin
spider-man things okay yeah yeah sweet
let's backpack right here
Ghostface 1301 says really want the
amazing spider-man 2012 suit
what's up caveman Austin how you doing
oh my god just tell us about the suits
well we're gonna do a suits video later
today is that Brandon says you can turn
off motion blur yes you can just good
all right so I got couple back things I
think I had to turn off motion blur or
something like that on doom cuz it was
making I was getting sick real bad so we
can unlock the Scarlet Spider or the
Nora see right now Roshan not to spam
DLC five times to get my attention but
do you'll see question work oh we don't
let me go with the Scarlet Spider you're
like a hipster that's how I look at it
you got like this little like cutoff oh
it is yeah yeah but it's not ghetto cuz
it's it's you know it's it's Lee yeah
like a bodybuilder wearing that he died
from fall damage
what's up is this an early release Alex
we're playing because we had you know
review copy but then also if technically
is out in Australia or a has been out
since what 5:00 a.m. or some 565 am yet
I'm Pacific I'm ravenous ass so is it
really only 20 to 25 hours of gameplay
it depends on how much you want a
complete of the game like all the
collectables yes if you want all the
collectables you'll be doing that for
quite some time I think closer that's 33
35 our 6s flashes why you swinging so
low swing so low that's how you get
speed okay okay
oh it's back back up here
Darth Rio says the age maze in the MCU
is perfect for how old Peter is right
now and for this game or is this Aunt
May is familiar with us because this is
the future no this is gross this is high
school t-shirt by the way he is and he's
now 23 sweet is this wrestler Spidey is
that what do know is that what it was
no he wore like I think like a red
sweater or something oh yeah because
there's more it was way more DIY it was
like way before he got though this whole
suit does it look good on the PS pro
we're actually on a pro right now I
think it looks great
wear the black suit please he didn't
have the research tokens oh no I haven't
no oh you do oh so do RC oh okay I
thought he meant the mark too let's go
visit uh
girlfriends here though
it's Pizza time people want to see I
think right here is the worth it if I
have to install eight months of
PlayStation updates I think so
Oh The Avengers time yeah so it's in the
game it's the tall I believe it's the
tallest building in the city so I'm
gonna go take a picture first subjective
frame oh that's a really close close a
landmark it's still counted okay so I
believe this is the tallest maybe the
dream forest tower that's coming in to
SF jintan women reminisce reminisce I
think sorry if I butchered your last
name okay I saw Cody container I it's
hard for me to say you know for I
haven't played it
Joey has played it he he says it in his
personal top 10 it's up there for him
still good it's not there for him but
who knows it's definitely you know
potentially part of the conversation but
it's kind of too early to talk about
goatee stuff but you know all we can do
on these streams is talk about our
personal favorites in terms of like the
games we're playing this year and the
ones we like a lot and you know come end
of the year that's one we'll do Game of
the Year and that's when you'll find out
if spider-man Marvel's spider-man makes
it on the list and if it does where it
lands etc etc but for now you know fall
without swinging please tell you did it
for him before just did it he hasn't
seen it yet oh yeah preemptively read
the chats mine he's a mind reader Joey
is Justin says looking forward for the
Catwoman DLC it's not Catwoman though it
was a black cat black cat yeah he told
me he got me Deadpool Deadpool emoji or
not that boy emoji with Deadpool logo
guy
oh my god that's scary but that's
exactly what I want you see no spider
slat sweat - now like the the xbox360
ones where if you miss the QTE it's like
fall flat on the ground
Dalton Duncan are there kids on the
street I don't know it's nighttime the
Guggenheim police and firefighters doing
a wonderful job there was crime sure but
nothing they couldn't of course we do
have things now we didn't have been
maniacs who shoot electricity out of
their eyes walking piles of sand you're
missing the point they didn't exist
before he came along at best he attracts
them I've often wondered if they're in
cahoots Wow
I've never actually heard anyone say
cahoots before oh I'd hate to imagine
what would have happened if all those
guys showed up in spider-man wasn't here
goodbye
no Nicholas you can't punch a civilian
the most I've seen Joey do is roll into
them on accident and they kind of fall
over
I'll give you your shadow seminole hi
hello we see you thanks for tuning in
appreciate it by the way just real quick
if you guys are wondering the voice of
Jay jonah jameson in the game is the
same guy who plays Reinhart and
overwatch oh really
yeah nice that guy's awesome if you are
walking on the street and you web sling
de Spiderman automatically jump or can
you run with a web in your hand
yourself up no so he'll automatically
well you'll only be able to web-swing if
you are in the air gotcha so like if I'm
holding our - he's just starts running
but this is where you said you have to
do that thing where you look for an
object to pull yourself up then jump
yeah so you can you can go like that and
pull yourself up there or you can just
kind of jump oh I see thugs you know
what we gotta do to these thugs guys
going off the building
he'll be attached it's okay that's some
men yeah it's like we're saying let's
Paulie I get some some sort of sandbag
oh that's new - he could very much be
huh I know that move looked like it
could kill someone yeah a lot of the
moves look like that oh oh I couldn't
grab it cool we're fighting in stunned
mode doesn't matter
I'm gonna kick this guy off how about
that
web swing
later a little jump rope action almost
so how many of those do you actually
think will get stuck to the law
you mean in as far as like what the game
will show how is he beating us cuz he
has superhuman powers what kind of
question is that
these are your thug that's why that is
exactly why you're a thug Oh kid see
they just think I'm a guy in the suit oh
whoops I scrolled up and lost my chat
there it's 30 FPS guys lock do you feel
the controller's vibrations while
website yes you do that so like the
closer you are to the ground like as
you're zooming past like cars and
everything it'll like vibrate pretty
good feedback kick gamer we have a like
review copy so we're playing because it
came out technically in Australia that's
how we have that's how we're playing
right now
hmm you're going off the building
or maybe not Dario said okay that look
cool there's reading a lot of cool stuff
so mm-hmm I don't know where to start oh
man there's some dudes here oh I don't
remember what this suit power does it
looks like something you would use to
sneak around yeah I think it was like oh
they don't call for backup when you
alert them oh that's pretty good why
don't you stay in this black and white
mode yeah for a little bit dodged it
nice the shield guys are a little tough
until you get a I like that there's a
sorry to cut you off there I just like
how there's like a good amount of
variation on the focus finisher yeah
just so that it never seems like old it
never seems like it really repeats or
very often
no they don't here aha distraction
that's your go-to I just want to get
them off there we go
yeah well that that'll be you get in
your butt whoops see you yeah
holy bounce off the wall he's so good
guys it's okay
there's he that spider-man doesn't kill
there's a little puddle there for you
guys to if you're looking for some
puddle action it's a big-ass bowl here
nice nice work
when steel Iron Man super in The
Avengers tower I continued man that
gameplay looks crazy yeah there's a lot
going on and a few and like you know
we're just at the beginning so we don't
have like full unlocks Yeti you'll get a
lot of new skills that will make it even
better honestly do we have any
have you tried counter-attacking a punch
I mean sort of
okay here's the one that is gonna yeah
the real this one's a good one so it's
the the point launch wasn't called the
point launch because the when you when
you zip to an area as a point launch a
boost
I mean have you made this tower you
scrambled it's coming on PC not uh that
we know of sandy for now ps4 so now
every time we do that uh that sip we can
jump at the right moment and they'll
give us a speed boosts Wow
you know you sold it more by making that
nice little noise I mean it visually
looks cool too but try to determine
enemy if they have yeah that's skill
they show us some more action let's get
some fight club going we just we just
had a Fight Club there Rockefeller
Center hi
ooh Radio City Music Hall like I really
like how the collectibles aren't just
collectibles are also the currency so it
gives you like incentive to like this
RAND Corporation did they incorporate
the touchpad at all in this game no so
it only brings up the map and that's it
back back here
have fun tomorrow with a with it Mike
Mitch sci-fi if you if you are playing
don't talk about Fight Club yeah we
already broke the rule
my bad we broke the rule apparently
you're really close to 50th and 7th so
you should check for it let's see what
stream my on it's so good
you're pretty lightweight you know if
I'm on Rockefeller t15 Rockefeller was
it 50th and 7th
yeah so we're trying to see if for some
reason the Marvel comic books towards oo
or headquarters you guys are good need a
map that's why I need
Brett fifth and 53rd so be this way I'm
really bad at
watching whoo don't hit spider-man now
did you thin 7/3
yeah highers wow this world is busy I
like it yeah there's always people all
over the place I mean New York if you've
ever been there
she intent says I I actually intern at
the Marvel office that's why I'm curious
or interested
all right we're almost there hopefully
gin time there's six there's a guy
spinning a sign hey you gotta come here
man yeah now open buy one get one free
that's pretty good BOGO deal he's pretty
good with the sign let's say that it's a
pizza finally get one free that's that's
a sweet deal I would do that for lunch
we just saw some puddles yeah you get
five experience from from givin people
high fives
that seems pretty cool to me all right
is this seventh year yeah this right
here uh time wants to know are you able
to just like hang from a web kind of
like that classic upside-down spot yes
it is
haven't been able haven't found a place
to do it yet but here we are we're on
50th and 7th Iran tan which quarter is
Ansari the Clinton son's friends
electronics will join us as the world is
missing children schools school buses
babies and animals there's pigeons
gotcha
got him got him if you guys didn't know
Joey has to yeah I'm a feather daddy
would say okay never heard that one
before but I will go with it
Times Square by the way we're right here
and John says air containing a hacking
squad staff to get pizza for lunch
we actually are close I was at Tony
Giovanni's a slice house I liked their
pizza pretty good I like all these like
fake birdies unless
Dave the man with the dark past the woes
of London Kate and Kevin views from the
veranda all these like would you watch I
think I think the man with the dark past
you sure first one doesn't know more
about first and last day first gear is
that even a thing in when you surf is
there a gear no fresh gear Oh fresh gear
my dad I'm so bad at reading picking on
my bro Pro bundle tomorrow what's up
Kane the one good to see you back I
guess good to see you on a non destiny
to stream where you don't just crap on
this steep to but I appreciate the
coming back I see some familiar faces in
chat which is awesome always awesome and
that could be any of you guys going down
the down the road I hope you guys are
enjoying your time with me and Joey I'm
usually on gamespot live here Monday to
Friday with different various other
video producers or editors from the
GameSpot team playing different games if
you haven't subbed to our YouTube
channel you should so you get notified
as to when we go live again when did a
Friday 11:00 a.m. PST and also when we
do cool features um
Joey's working on working on a show that
some of you guys and gals may have seen
already potato mode that's you know a
pretty fun thing to see if you haven't
seen it before where we take some really
pretty looking games and turn it into
mush and then you got some other fun
features coming out like Mike who tries
and plays games that have been out for a
while but you know they either get big
updates or things like that where you
know should you give this game a second
chance Jake's been working on a
nostalgia trip which is us going back to
some old school games seeing if they
hold up and yeah I feel like I'm missing
a bunch of stuff but that's just some of
the cool stuff you could see on baseball
calm as well as our reviews and of games
at we gave spider-man and
where we going Joey well a little slow
motion oh it's because you're when
you're when you am named are you trying
to trying to find a space a spot that I
can hang upside down by me it's in the
game it's just a certain specific spot I
guess here I could do here good work
I've seen a spider do that I was like
come on just go to the ground so I could
kill you
super wheelie says your reviews are far
superior to iTunes well we appreciate
that thank you
you know as much as it is a competition
with the IGN you know we still have
friends there and I think you know
sometimes competition is a good thing it
kind of helps us you know aim to be
better not just for ourselves but I'm
sure the same can be said for them so
there are some animals right there
pigeons thank you our case we're kind of
sick so to all you guys hanging out
today really appreciate it it's been a
it's been a good time so we are now
flying through the city I think I can't
tell if that's a question or an answer
Maz but they wanted to know how you get
that drone the drone yeah
was that a drone was that no in your
unlocks just now was that I saw it was
it a gadget it was gadget so there is a
drone there's a spider drone that you
gotta get at level 8 ok gotcha well 6
right now yeah and as I mentioned for
some there is the ability to turn off
motion blur so are you seeing what they
did to Sony HQ in Foster City no they
did a spider-man thing they put so that
like the the Sony campus at least here
in California is like kind of like - not
super tall buildings but there's two
buildings and like you know there's they
put a web across it what the spider-man
oh really looks really good at night my
friend sent me some pictures
patience my team where is the file
there's someone else here they must have
taken it masks look at that texture on
the mask when did they start speaking
thanks I've work man I thought you've
always been sub I see you all the time
T's new potato mode I think it'll be in
a couple weeks yeah we're gonna taking a
break for a rake spider-man stuff from
busy busy work around yeah it's time but
it'll return next Friday and big games
are coming out soon too so I'm sure Joe
we got will have his crack it like black
ops like battlefield and things like
that so how many more hours till it
launches as xscape the matrix I think it
depends on where region you're in some
people have it already some people are
like almost soon and some people wait a
little longer
do the Avengers serve plot in any way or
is it just a cool user egg no it's just
an easter egg there they are not in game
at all gotcha
so you just distracted him right
essentially you're like yeah so you can
like shoot webs on the floor and be like
hey look over here eyes on the floor all
right
your goal here on this mission is to try
to stealth as much of it as you can okay
oh actually you know what I take that
back chat do you want him to you know
just beat all these thugs up or do you
want to see some more tactical
spider-man gameplay I'll leave it up to
you careful oh you know we can do - you
could try the suit power later oh yeah
that's right if things get bad I guess a
little unnecessary yeah all right and
they won't see the guy you just knocked
out or I'm gone now dang she's thrown
that person under the bus stealth
stealth a lot of people say stealth okay
naturally stealth a lot of stuff Oh
someone's like well he doesn't kill it
would be beat him up a lot of stuff all
right we're doing stealth we're gonna
try it we're gonna do our best then if
it gets bad then we'll beat him up there
you go and as karma said if you mess up
then there's just no more self just show
yeah just just do what we got to I like
this Thank You Chad appreciate it like
to try to get you guys involved when we
can oh he's safe and grab it's
interesting that tells you he's saved to
a cool
[Music]
hey what is that what is that is this
hello say camera oh it's a camera like
how you can still hear the guy like a
web Duff in the background corner who
dad we mean who dad working at least it
was she was yours yeah so Robbie's got
you covering a break-in for the bugle
whoa Robbie doesn't what's that really
know I'm here and it wasn't a break-in
until a few minutes ago
Thanks uh-huh let me explain 70% stuff
ooh
50 minutes earlier
excuse me hi Mary Jane Watson I am
covering the Fiske estate sale hello
Craig said we do this tomorrow
I like to get a jump on people look like
him do just shot him in the head don't
you'll have to come back tomorrow right
okay
I'm sorry hey Craig no sorry it just it
looks like we're gonna have to run
something else on the cover I don't know
maybe the expressionist piece MJ knows
you Spidey yeah I think way later though
that's why you're here no moment like
the present Thank You grace
there's never mind what you would do to
get out of some trouble look around and
familiarize yourself with the items I'll
be waiting by the baku statue when
you're ready to begin can do can do the
Wilson Fisk collection assume this is
all the kingpin stuff that he's stolen
probably like how can he have a
collection like if he's a criminal or
whatever I mean he's like doesn't he I
don't know I don't need to he's got
money that's all that matters
did she get the I hearts why t-shirt
Pete got away collapsed in my yard half
dead and I had to steal my dad's car to
drive him to the ER the first of many
nurse MJ moments eighteenth-century okay
where are we going you tell me you're
ready to begin sounds good don't touch
the art how do you get new agility
skills i agility skills oh I mean like
the wood would change got a level up
yeah it's just as every time you level
up you'll get the skill point you can
spend it in that tree beautiful it's a
Matheny correct mr. Fiske has
exceptional taste did you know him well
before his arrest in a professional
context I handled many of his sales
let's move on please don't ask me too
much about my dealings with their
criminal now this exquisite piece
exemplifies the traditional to Russia
commie
huddled ink effect the two neo are so
imposing Neil CY Pisgah liked this piece
you ready for neo - I still doubt that
I'm excited I still thought it was weird
to show it like I thought so really I
thought it was really fast because it
was like what we just was like a year
later oh he's like until the release
yeah sorry it's it was only been a it
had only been about a year right since
it had first release yeah that they then
now have a second one next year that's
gonna be wasn't the year the bleed cuz
he got neo - you have Sakura you know
you have presumably goes to sushi yeah
that's why I thought it was weird
exactly why it was in that same
presentation you know where they showed
goes to Tsushima and then they also
showed me although they are different
games like they have similar aesthetics
yeah
rested so I just thought it was weird I
thought they could have easily held off
another year yeah they're like
remastering I know any wishes or no no
you're right you're right sorry
warlords right yeah yeah I thought it
was switch but I think yeah you'd know
you're right sorry
I think there's something else yeah well
really yeah it's switch it switch ps4
Xbox one and PC regarding activities I
don't think your readers would have any
interest in dammit
wait here please oh we got it you got a
Marvel and DC Valley I'm not gonna get
into that also if we go off movie
success outside of like the Nolan
trilogy and maybe some of the old
Batman's follow me I mean I've always
been more of a Marvel person myself but
I did kind of grow up watching like yeah
it's really good but I you know I'd wake
up watch spider-man watch x-men think
they'll ever come out with a new x-men
animated TV show I don't know I'm
actually surprised there hasn't been one
by now like everything's been a
throwback you know yeah so held there's
a there's a freaking bumblebee
standalone movie oh my gosh what like
that just came out of nowhere
this is another transformer movie I was
like oh no no but Asia loves
transformers like yeah they love it
they're making it they're make it for
them
if she's not your reporter who is she
playing Shh oh we got caught in my
auction house oh my god no I do not
trust you to fix this oh what's what how
did she not hear the part closed the
door what are you doing she's not the
cops take it I know this statue opens
don't get caught haha she's in cahoots
Oh Jamison would say you look so like
kind and loving in that picture you know
all right so we got a statute to work on
here yeah cuz you gotta figure out how
to I like opening it I guess or
something
well geisha painting okay couple more
things
she's cozy with ask these for still
holds up the at Beast Wars
dude I was very jarring for me at first
as a kid like because I was so used to
just like normal transformers but dude
these wars was awesome Optimus Primal
and what I hate a Waspinator so so much
until a Starscream took over him and he
was a badass for like one episode where
Waspinator was like literally owning
everyone that's the kingpin are you sure
common power mouth closed left arm down
right palm facing forward mouth closed
left arm down right palm facing forward
I feel like that's what I need to do to
this guy I love this Marvel vs. DC
battle in the chat it's hilarious
because my fiance grew up watching DC so
she's very DC yeah even though she's
still like some Marvel movies but she'll
she'll always try to like support or
like you know represent for DC and she's
like yeah Suicide Squad it was a good
movie I'm like I did not like Suicide
Squad I think she liked Justice League
and I was like no no thanks but I'll let
the chat continue to don't chats about
that maybe I should turn the head
whoa is hand opened up on his own who's
long as this section we'll probably
almost there yeah we are take this one
and are there more missions like this
putting his hand that's not right
there's there aren't a lot if that's
you're afraid of well gets we'll get
back to Spidy Spidy stuff very soon halo
in the clouds bring up the new predator
movie
he says he's like the trailer so far
that was another weird one for me it's
like dragon's breath you know those oh
the it's like freeze-dried it's not
freeze dry it's like nitrogen infused
cereal yeah pretty much like fruit loops
or their balls yeah but they're like
they taste like reverbs pretty much I
think they're like very expensive over
there yeah like it's a novelty yeah just
so that when you breathe out like she in
here oh there you go nee-chan summer
I was on my way to the exit when I saw
you [ __ ] stay away huh you saved five
minutes ago listen whoever these masked
guys are there after this file but I'll
never get it out of here well the place
is swarming with them right okay um you
hide back there I take out the bad guys
you make a break when it's clear that's
a good plan it's a little wrist wear oh
those are is like good to see you Pete
the web shooters and you two not exactly
how I pictured us meeting again now
honey it's exactly how I pictured it
dang flirty so flirty MJ did she change
your perfume focus focus
all right these guys out before I
Pandora's box
not much Chuck Fisk we need to get you
in that file out of here hang tight
there we go all right well still we
haven't really talked about too many of
the suits super wheelie we probably
won't be recraft what we want cuz in a
way by theorycrafting then you'll know
that they're not in the game let's
sucker says I'm gonna go I don't want to
anymore there's no problem you do you
thanks for stopping by I appreciate it
that sounded accurate safe not safe
what is that gotta stay solid oh you can
use your thing later
oh no that's only if they get alerted
right yeah I think those two guys should
totally see this right
oh no the other side okay I got masks on
- so it's harder to see yours their
vision their peripheral aren't as good
okay so how about good question who is
the best on-screen spider-man McGuire
Garfield our Hall and I'm gonna go fall
in
mmm hey you're like I kinda like Babar a
little bit really I mean this is only
because I haven't seen home guy even
though I can anti-slip hearing some yeah
hi
let's destroy this Museum other lady
doesn't know how to hide oh there she
goes
put your hands up and running right in
the middle oh yeah that's a good
question why isn't he dead do one thing
real quick you can cheat so cool thing
you can change the suits and suit powers
in the middle of combat nice which I go
into web blossom ninja I haven't put on
the noir suit why not
now you look kind of like down
web everything so good oh you're still
here and Fisk I'm so sorry for your
business's loss
oh he's got a little like not a sight
it's like the sickle signal yeah come
guess up oh you got already have a
finisher is that one in my back pocket
just saving that hold on he's got
company though come get some
oh there's another guy Oh God really
like that slide into the legs well if I
just stay up here can't get me right Tom
Holland nailed Peter and spider-man says
retros yeah I'm drawing with that Toby
did spider-man wrong says redress yeah
okay this is a sticky situation
Oh dad hey oh eh well I'm a web um oh no
that's not the right oh no sorry oh yeah
too busy weapon the man had a gun
there's each you two have something
special yeah it has its own ability oh
my days the damage this is why maybe
defense tree exists no just brute force
all the best defense is a good offense
keep them out of the air no ok see you
have to there's like a little bit of
startup when you like jump in the air so
can they cancel it on you yeah they can
like interrupted what's on your mask my
booty check our exercise has good
gameplay though really game looks really
good yep
huh looks antique I think I know someone
who could help track down where this
came from dad each mask is an antique
you know how much that would cost how
come you're able to play the game ready
we have early review code I just talked
to Craig and technically it's an
Australian work for heritage arts nurse
that I did hi Mary Jane Watson Daily
Bugle mmm-hmm you will not write a word
of what you saw the record what do you
know about the file those masked men
stole your camera strap little
spider-man pieces all nails your editor
will be hearing from our attorney
what's up rocket star thanks I think the
last six months never happened what
happened in last six months whoa this
makes not good enough for her
yeah you know we're definitely fortunate
and blessed to be able to play some of
these games early for sure we're not
gonna talk too much about the like Seuss
we haven't unlocked but if you want to
check out all the suits later we have
them and we're gonna put up a video on
what they look like and what they do all
right real quick I am going to skip the
cinematic okay reasons that I will not
say okay good thing Joey's here coulda
gave you a big spoiler there but we
won't all right back to web-swing
don't touch so hard we might have
leveled up maybe hope so 2750 M sounds
like a lot go on so you'll get a log
experience for the story missions like
way more than any of the crime and you
got skill point which is always good
shaaka we're gonna fight the Shaka Emmy
Fox was the shot Gary it wasn't you or
electro electro I was just thinking that
in my head just some something like
electricity
looks like a picture oh but you didn't
watch um I'm not gonna say anything
actually
alright let's spend that skill point on
sug can you guys put the classic suit on
if you have the undamaged of hers oh
yeah
can they spin to the ground yeah you
don't do that
there's no splats here so you unlocked
whoa secret war suit so I'll know what
this one's from let's see arms race
discharges amplified EMP to disable
their weapons so that's not fair
nailed it stuck the landing oh it's bad
guys they're holding up a phone shock
just which I do in or the lab which I
don't worry doc Spidey Ceaser earned LGA
so you unlock them via levels but then
you also have to get like tokens and
things like that that you earn from like
doing different activities in the game
that then give you the ability to like
unlock the actual super bully yeah you
explain that right yes sorry what were
you laughing about I was laughing
because these guys were holding up the
the phone store but I was the one that
ended up breaking the glass kind of
crazy to rob a storefront in the city
spider-man protects yeah you're for real
man sit tight guys a nice comfy paddy
wagon will be here soon oh let's spend
that skill point
okay we're doing ear tricks and if so
how many tokens and which would I need
to craft it that I don't know you'd have
that Joey was the undamaged 104 the
undamaged one I think I think you get
that pretty early on I don't remember if
you actually need to unlock it unlock it
yeah again we're only like maybe a
little bit farther now but we like
earlier were seven percent into the game
yeah okay so still very early so I just
got the air tricks so now we can do
flips and stuff in the air sweet and you
actually get experience for that in case
you're wondering too XP baby but you
could just keep doing it dragon roll
spider roll it sounds like a sushi let
me give you back flips dang ol moonsault
this is perfect with the music
twists
somehow Andres Vuitton says don't even
have the game yet it's already my
favorite game hands down
that is a very strong opinion but I'm
happy that you are looking forward to
playing it Jacob
silver says McGuire was an okay
spider-man Garfield was in the back
great in Holland it was amazing all
right I don't know she'd spoil myself
too much that staff to me Lord so he
snakes like off no worries they're
stopping by touch Adam thanks for
watching can you upgrade the web shooter
or just earn more weapons for them no
you can so each one of the gadgets that
you get has like its own path for like
upgrades so actually I think I might be
able to do that for this one Artie King
gaming asking does the control does the
game use the controller speaker at all
no I have not I don't believe I've heard
it okay so we'll go well create the
impact web actually Colin says try
chaining multiple stunts for a lot of
you XP you're gonna need some to get a
couple of tricks off I think if you're
gonna try to do like you know drag him
into a spider into it yeah you need to
go moonsault pretty high up it's extreme
or if you can yeah we'll go till about
one probably maybe a little bit more but
Joey's a pretty busy man especially with
spider-man out and him being one of the
couple people in the office it's 100
percent it so fortunately stream for too
much longer but you know really
appreciate everyone hanging out we're
gonna do a little bit more of course go
a little longer than usual
see what we got
so is it possible to get every possible
upgrade yes
so if you're worried about like skill
trees in that like if you go on one too
much you won't be able to get the rest
on the other trees by in the game you'll
have everything it just it's just more
of like what do you want now chase to be
a cool Oh backpack time long time got
backpacks to collect Steven - it's
actually 30 FPS the game and there's
motion blur so this game out asking
Apple waffles it's out for some people
not out for everyone and a cops back
when they thought I was working with
electro yes gaming videos and can have
different powers on their releases that
is pretty cool and as Joey mentioned the
other cool things you could do at mid
combat so yeah Bob 2006 where she
actually can't wait that's why when you
win look at me you have a crater yeah
yeah yeah hey there sorry I almost
killed you
oh yeah oh they always happen that they
almost got a pic of that almost got pick
up a spider-man hug are you guys gonna
be looking for those JanSport backpack
bags all over the city of course man
remember JanSport backpack oh god yeah
I'm sure there's still a thing there's
they still are well like them yeah and
then the trendy thing to do is have like
a what is that Hershel Hershel z /
follow me come back some going Arjuna
says this looks amazing no pun intended
there are gonna use different seasons
Robert we actually you have swapped a
couple times now with the ones that we
have unlocked so you know you can scrub
through the VOD if you want to watch
them with that as mentioned earlier and
throughout the stream we are gonna do an
all suits
video compilation that we hope to get up
by the end of the day if not sooner so
stay tuned to that if you're trying to
see like the suits and you know their
different powers
that's a lot of landmarks treacherous
asking do you need tokens to earn the
undamaged suits if I'm correct you only
get the damaged plastic suit after
beating a boss I know cuz weren't all
the stingy learnt all the suits like you
unlock it right from leveling up despite
her having stuff it scare sorry I just
get access to the zoo thinking was as
you live yeah but you don't know mock it
with until you have the tokens to
correct yes how far are you guys into
the game says Taggart like 10 percent
maybe and the games up like roughly 25
to 30 hours maybe more if you feel
absolutely everything
so whatever 10 percent is of that so
three hours maybe 2.5 okay Joe James
Tyler wants to know have any other
superhero show not yet another example
of the explosion in mass criminals
since Spiderman came on the scene let's
hear on
[Music]
but did you try to do like three tricks
in three different tricks in around we
mean like someone saying if you change
the different moves you'll get a lot
more XP oh yeah you can if you do like
fragment a Rhino almost killed me until
I broke this chip off his horn and
figured out what his costumes made of
still wasn't easy to beat him my back
still aches just thinking about it it's
nice looking a worn spider-man has a lot
of unpaid bills the spider-man get any
in-game currency to pay them off
probably not can you turn off the
podcast that oh yeah you can turn it off
okay I always like having long because
hilarious alright this is high enough
right you can do a couple tricks
spider roll fighter flying he likes
tricks which flying helix triple helix
moonsault another moonsault I'm not sure
how much that added up to like 30 like
30 do a flip we did one sort of ooh
McTwist oh there's so much stuff over
there oh what the car is getting away
stop this guy
[Music]
just shoot these criminals are accurate
man Oh cries in the driver
that's cool
glad I stopped that too many crazy
drivers crime tokens stalker know to
upgrade your abilities you just have to
level up essentially and you'll get
skill points which will then give you
the ability to unlock different skills
in the tree drug traits gotten more
aggressive post Fisk dump that out yeah
maybe I can still this these guys are
clearly not worried about anyone
catching them selling your rugs and this
what though you won't stay there
whatever even web these guys I like that
there's like different things you can do
to kind of like get more like experience
yeah where the tokens hey why are these
guys here I don't know I was gonna ask
you actually
I know that is that Frankensteiner like
the Cammy move don't remember so I got
three crime delegates for that by doing
both the bonus objectives okay
are you guys excited for venom and
spider-man far from home yeah I mean oh
here's what they're gonna do with venom
I really hope that somehow carnage makes
his way into it if not just at least a
teaser for like another movie or
something but I mean cuz we've gotten to
the point where we had r-rated Marvel
movies at this point right so it's like
I could understand why you could you
couldn't have a carnage character before
because he's basically a murderer right
but makes sense right we'll see don't
want to do story missions just yeah I
mean we're yeah we have sub like 15
minutes so like you can kind of do
something like the map is big but it
never feels like you know if you have to
go to the other side of the city you're
not like oh man I have to go so far
because it's like the swing is it gets
you there pretty quickly we got you can
do some tricks and it just says Jesus
the game runs at 30fps for all those
people talking about frames and stuff
like that the game runs at 30fps with
motion blur that you can have on or off
so streams shouldn't be lagging if it's
lagging for you guys check your internet
connection etcetera I like taking
pictures while I'm swinging of the
United Nations shook up
here is it where is it what Conda you
active Panther dude stuff but that still
probably hurt it's not it's purple at
night I don't think I've gone by this
anything check Jana yes like there's
like the the dr. strange building
earlier we see that the wakandan embassy
Oh is he confirmed I didn't know that I
know like riot and there's like a couple
other symbiotes wait so is venom Marvel
Studios or is it still like Sony I think
it's Sony but it's I think you know I
think ever since the I want to say that
Marvel is something something in or
whatever yeah but I'm not a hundred
percent sure I was like that's a chat
cuz when Spiderman went over to like
Marvel Studios he did they just only
take spider-man or like it cuz they say
no we want to do a VIN a movie so give
us the rights for that that's true I
don't I don't remember I'm sure somebody
in chat will tell us
people complaining about that we learn
how to turn it on to HD well you mean
the street okay so Shahin says Sony
venomous Tony not MCU so does MCU not
even are they not even involved for like
in the little like the slightest bit it
dude
based on the trailer didn't seem like
okay or seemed didn't seem like it would
be able to just be like its stand a
little thing can you go to Queens no
only man hands unfortunately although I
would like to see him do like Brooklyn
and Johnny hey it's your future game or
something oh it's one of my favorite
side missions you'll see what thanks for
the heads up miss let me know if I can
help I'll keep an eye on the activities
from up here
thanks for the assist Stephanie well I
would armed men be a Belvedere Castle
kind of hunch they're not tourists now
this game even released it yet I mean
for some people yes Tegan but not
everyone Australia hasn't already
I'm guessing Europe's gonna have it soon
ish I can't my ability to time convert
it is not so great
fists man this isn't good going in
height oh no they saw me whatever I
can't see
that's all of them let's find out what
they were up to guys here's the main
villain we're not talking about that how
long is it to platinum I don't know
platinum I want to say that in order
plan you'll have to clear these
benchmarks here so just in case you're
wondering the game keeps track of like
the moves that you do and like enemies
that you defeat and whatnot and so these
will fill up to like three levels I
think that's a lot of work
go bean bros yeah we saw the Avenger
tower earlier and we just passed like
wakandan embassy all right here we go
not sure what's going on here I can get
from this flash drive a bird just stole
a flash drive full of evidence pigeon
great I'll check it out that's actually
inaccurate because pidge's nest all year
round
AJ Espinoza says spider-man is owned by
Sony however the heel is Pretoria meant
to have his own two movies done by
Marvel Studios and appear in for Maurice
I see thank you how many suits come with
the game 27 it's pretty good and though
continuously add more as through like
DLC and like updates to the game
can you beat the game in one day good
luck I mean maybe if you stay up a whole
day or if you just speed through and do
any other ya know side stuff at all just
chasing birds
yeah I'm chasing birds that's hilarious
our pigeons they ran away with the flash
revenue they're pretty fast how are they
faster than you Joey do you all that
homie pigeons they can fly up to 70
miles an hour I did not know this they
go very good this is something only a
pigeon owner I feel like would know
although I did the other day on like a
grassy field not that a religion but
they were like like a flock of geese
there's you hanging out like sitting
like they're like hanging out sitting
and yeah eating whatever and then all of
a sudden while one's just like starts
you know making noise and then they all
take off I was like holy gravy like saw
something they're like oh lordy bird was
like we got to go and they all just like
took off as very kind of cool how can
you play already hack no backdoor game
spot we review games so we have access
to the game early network also it's
technically out in Australia that's why
we can yeah
[Music]
good morning Joey you got two minutes
and 25 seconds to stop I'm not gonna
make it Jillian Thompson says how many
species of birds are in the game think
just pinions Wi-Fi coverage but if
you're wondering there are several
different types of Asians the game not
gonna go into that much detail
dang it's back up that's funny I almost
want like a DMC like grading thing
stylish oh yeah 123 how long has this
game it's around 25 to 30 hours but it
definitely could be longer if you're
like trying to platinum or if you're
trying to do a lot of like getting all
the collectables and everything so you
know you could spend more than 30 hours
there yeah and like potentially I feel
like a lot of is gonna be spent just
swinging around just because it's so
much fun
no shield for you I have that ability
seem like too good on me it doesn't kill
them though unless unless it unless it
webs them against a wall like they have
to be against the wall for that to
happen well they have to be like a near
one of them or you can take them and
like throw them into a wall okay vegans
like in the combat know are you sure
pigeons are flying rats defended the
bird they are I'm on my way I need to
get to Stephanie before Fisk's men do
she wouldn't be involved if it weren't
for me yeah way to go tell me I'm coming
how do they know
how can they possibly know given how far
away maybe they tracked her phone or
whatever Christophe wants to know the
airspeed velocity of an unladen to
swallow I don't know if Joey has that
much bird knowledge oh I've never seen
him do that before
sorry whoever's down there that's it
keep it safe rats are ground pigeon
thank you
your eagle eye stopped an incarcerated
crime boss from harvesting half the
city's personal data not too shabby huh
plus I found a nest of red-breasted
nuthatch is when you triple kick that
guy in the face real beauties too you
want to check them out thanks but I
think I'll focus on jailbirds for now
all right Joey I think that's good oh we
got one more level Oh
all right why don't you check that out
for a bit oh no new suits but we do have
a new suit and a couple new suit mods oh
I don't have enough we just buy one
anyway
man of crime tokens new skills oh this
one also very good quickly all of that
webslinger I know it's like I just like
the movement of the game so when you
land just go straight back into the air
even from like a hella tall bit like
height mm-hmm so anytime you land you
can quick cover like right afterwards
you just be just go around the city like
this it's really working on leg day son
go tendon there wants it now
you Patrick asking is this a goodbye if
you're not a big sweaty fan yes I would
say so because I honestly I'm not even a
big experiment and like I'd have you
obviously haven't it's kept up with the
movies or like the comics or anything
like that but it's just it's just so
much fun
all right I'm gonna wrap you up after
this tower I don't want to show
something off oh yeah all right well
watches this tower unlocks here all
right well I appreciate everyone
stopping by checking out like kind of an
early slice of Spider Man Marvel
spider-man it'll be out for the
remainder of the world you know as it
comes as time progresses it's already
out in Australia I'm sure other regions
are slowly but surely getting them so
thank you all for tuning in of course
check out the review gamespot.com
we gave it a 9 it's also on YouTube of
course if you want to watch it any last
thoughts Joey now that you've had a good
you know I mean you've played a lot more
this too but but it's it's worth saying
that this is a game that is like I would
say it's worth getting a hundred percent
on Wow
just like just playing a lot of it like
even beyond just the story there's so
much to do in the game I feel like and
like there's gonna be like good
nostalgia for people that actually do
like really care about spider-man
yeah alright so it's like I mentioned
earlier still great game for people that
maybe not necessarily like the biggest
spider-man yeah if if someone who isn't
all that into spider-man can love a game
loved the game that much like I do think
there's even more for the people that
love spider-man yeah so check it out
happy launch day for those you know that
have it or are waiting I hope you guys
enjoy playing it when you as soon as you
guys can and yeah we'll see you guys
next time tomorrow I think at 11:00 John
Luke and Ben are gonna do some halo with
the community so if you guys want to
play Halo with us
come on Fridays because we do community
streams on Friday but until then
you so much again Joey and until I see
you on another stream probably over
watch oh yeah remember that most likely
it's to see y'all later
bye Spidey time
[Music]